The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So just as kind
of a synopsis of
some ideas that we're
going to get through, we're
looking at manufacturing, which
is a way to profit
from innovation,
as a way to scale innovation.
And we'll do something of an
historical review here today,
so we'll look at the last big
competitiveness challenge.
The US went through a challenge
from Germany and Japan.
We'll take a particular look
at Japan's manufacturing
innovations in the '70s.
We'll review a distributed
model of production
that the US came up with,
in some ways in response.
We'll look at manufacturing
and innovation
organizational shifts
within both Korea and Japan,
and then talk a bit about how
the nature of the competition
is changing as well.
So that's kind of a
backdrop, and then next week
will be a more pointed focus.
So the first piece we'll go
through, and I'll lay it out.
And Chris, do you have--
RASHEED, you've got Hughes.
RASHEED: Yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right, OK.
So this is Kent Hughes.
Kent Huges led the joint
economic committee,
staff director in the Congress.
He was a senior official in
the Department of Commerce.
And he kind of wrote the
history of the competition
over production between US
and China, a period of time
when he was very deeply
engaged in policy making.
So let's get this
backdrop kind of down
because I think
it'll help us see
a lot about what the US is
going through now in terms
of manufacturing.
So in the 1970s, the
US faced a mess--
intractable high inflation,
declining productivity growth,
therefore a slow growth rate,
rising economic competition,
rising national anger,
frustration with government.
Sound familiar?
And the US model of kind of
pretty unfettered markets
of limited government
support for industry
was a very different
innovation model,
innovation system than
what Japan and Germany were
pursuing.
And that in turn led
to the beginnings
of what could be called the
US National Competitiveness
Strategy.
So the essential
elements of that history
of the initial response to
Japan's development of quality
manufacturing, which we'll
get into in a minute,
there were different
responses from each party.
And these will be
familiar to you as well.
So each party was organized--
remember when we discussed
classical economics, right?
And the key factors
in classical economics
were capital supply
and labor supply.
Each of our parties is organized
around one of these, right?
So the capital supply response
came from the Republican side,
and Congressman Jack Kemp
of Buffalo and Bill Roth,
who was chairman of
the Finance Committee
and the Senate from
Delaware, their argument was,
let's adjust marginal
tax rates that
will spur capital
availability and investment.
And we'll recover.
The Democrats will
organize around
their traditional
mantra of labor supply,
broadly defined, right?
And they had moved
towards what was then
known as industrial
policy, still known
as industrial policy.
So they were looking to
rescuing failing industries
and reorganizing
them for turnarounds.
And at a later time, through
the Young Commission,
another set of ideas begins to
enter the discussion around,
quote, sunrise industries.
The Young Commission tired to
cut between these two party
perspectives and develop
a different approach.
So John Young was head
of Hewlett Packard,
and President Reagan named him
the head of this commission.
And their focus was on
national competitiveness.
And they concurred that things
like fiscal and monetary policy
are important.
But they were also interested
in what the innovation side
of the research side could do.
So it was not simply
a governmental role
in basic research,
but basic technology.
And they developed
a model that was
in this public private
partnership that
was industry led.
And the term partnership
nation emerged
from some of their work.
So this was, in effect, a
third way out of the box.
The two parties had their
underlying theories.
And Young walks in with a
different kind of approach.
So he's out of the
Silicon Valley.
He's used to working with DARPA
and the Defense Department,
so he's not afraid of government
and its technology support
rule.
And this whole effort
was called the New Growth
Compact, all right?
So it was an attempt to
cut between the parties
and develop a series of
new programmatic elements.
So some of the things
that eventually emerged--
not specifically from the
recommendations necessarily,
but emerged over time--
were created as
cooperative R&D agreements
with industry between
governmental laboratories
and industry.
So in other words, we've got
these snappy governmental labs.
Little emerges from them.
Could we do
cooperative agreements
to get technologies
out of the labs
into the hands of industry?
It's a new tool.
The Bayh-Dole Act comes out
of the same time period,
which, prior to the Bayh-Dole
Act, the federal government
owned the fruits of
the research that it
supported at universities.
Now the federal government
is not a commercial entity,
so nothing happened to it.
So it was moved
to shelves, right?
The IP was not really utilized.
So Bayh and Dole came up
with the idea of giving
the universities that had
sponsored the research
activities-- supported the
research activities with
federal funds--
let's give them ownership.
And they in turn typically
share it with their researchers
and give them a vested stake
in developing the technologies
that the research is leading to.
So this plays a
really critical role
in starting to put universities
on the playing field
as innovation actors, right?
It gives them a stake in the
outcomes of their research.
The Advanced Technology Program
and the Manufacturing Extension
Program come out of the Commerce
Department in an attempt
to introduce both new
technologies and an attempt
in the MEP program
to bring advances
Japan had been pushing
on quality production
into small US manufacturers.
There were education proposals.
That attitude was
essentially pro-trade.
In other words, don't
ignore the world.
Let's be successful at trade
and be innovative in trade.
That attitude gets adopted
by the Clinton administration
and leads to things like
NAFTA and the China WTO.
So that's kind of what is coming
out of the Young Commission
in terms of new ideas, but
let's go back to the challenge
that they were facing.
What was this?
What was this new
model around production
that Japan was launching?
And I would argue that
was big enough so that it,
in fact, amounted to a
significant innovation wave.
And it was the one
wave that the US
missed in the second
half of the 20th century.
So Japan hit on innovating
and manufacturing
as a way towards its
own competitiveness
as a leading world
economic power.
And before the 1970s,
the US had come up
with a way of dealing with
quality in what's called
a quality price tradeoff.
So in our mass
production system--
and the US essentially
came up with most
of the elements
of mass production
starting around the 1840s
and moving for 100 years.
The US had become
a dominant mass
produ-- we had really invented
mass production at huge scale.
And we were selling
manufactured goods
into a continent sized economy.
Of course, continent sized
economy that existed.
And part of the
mass production idea
was never stop the
production line.
Always keep it moving.
Always keep producing.
And how do you
deal with quality?
Well, you do
statistical analysis
of the products
you were producing.
You would decide that some fixed
percentage were not meeting
those quality standards.
And so at the end of the
system, after you would produce
the goods, you would have an
inspection group throw out
whatever it was--
1.8%, 2.4%, whatever the
statistical number told you--
after the production
system had been developed.
Quality is really how
good is the product.
Quality control is
what's the unit of--
are there units
of equal quality,
right, across all
that you're producing?
Japan came up with a
completely different system
and a much better system.
And it was called
here the Toyota model.
But it was based in
Japanese manufacturing.
So the idea here was build
quality into each product,
not at the end of the system,
throw a bunch of stuff away.
Ensure that the entire system
is working to ensure quality.
And anyone, any worker, can
stop the production line
if they see a quality problem.
So catch it at the
beginning and build quality
into your entire
production process.
The idea came actually from an
American named Edward Deming.
And he was unable to persuade
US manufacturers to adopt
this model.
So he takes it to Japan.
And we sense
Japan's rich culture
here around
craftsmanship, right?
It fits wonderfully with it.
All right, so this is--
Japanese samurai culture, of
course, respects the samurai,
but accords almost
equivalent respect
to the sword maker, right, who
is almost equally as famous.
So there's a huge focus on
high quality and craftsmanship
in Japanese culture.
So what Deming is saying
fits with the kind
of culture of Japan.
There are other pieces
that Japan comes up with--
just in time inventory.
In other words, a major
burden that manufacturers face
is that they have to store
up a lot of inventory
to have enough goods
available for the marketplace.
But when you hit an
economic downturn,
then you're stuck with
this massive inventory
that you can't
get rid of, right?
And it becomes a huge cost
burden on your system.
Japan's idea was produce for
what the market is actually
absorbing--
in other words, produce just
in time to get it to market.
So that calls for
a whole new level
of efficiency and
communications really
IT embedded in
earlier kind of ways
throughout the whole
production system.
And it significantly
reduced the exposure
of significant manufacturers
to economic downturns.
Japan integrated its dealers and
its suppliers into its system.
So in the US,
major manufacturers
would keep their suppliers at
arm's length and have them bid.
And there was no
particular relationship.
They were just looking for
the lowest price, right?
Japan, the suppliers
were actually
integrated into that system.
And in turn, the dealers who
were just selling these goods
were also integrated in, so
that you had much closer touch
with what customers
actually needed and wanted,
as well as what the
quality of the suppliers,
what they were producing,
is going to be.
Japan had a culture of
respecting the production
moment.
So they would move
their engineers
onto the factory floor as
their first set of assignments.
So if you look at, in contrast,
the US didn't do that.
All right?
So the engineering
profession was
one in the 19th century
US that was trying
to take a hold with those
other established professions--
doctors, lawyers, ministers.
So when you look at these
early photographs of MIT
and you look at
photographs of MIT
labs, those wonderful
photographs of the steam lab,
you can't imagine coal
dust all over the place.
These characters
were all wearing
these starched white shirts
with those fancy weird bow
ties they wore at the end
of the 19th century, right?
They looked so prim and proper.
They're trying to be like
ministers or doctors, right?
They're trying to
elevate their profession
and separate themselves in a
way from the work floor right?
So the engineers want to
be in a glassed up area up
above the factory
floor in the US, right?
They don't want
to be down with--
heaven forbid-- the workforce.
So it's an attempt by
an engineering culture
to establish its identity.
You can understand
why it happened.
But Japan hit on a much
better plot, right?
Integrate the engineers
in the workforce
and make them one, right?
Much better, right?
So we have learned to get
our engineers into the mix
in the manufacturing sector.
Japan came up with this
quality manufacturing model.
Sometimes we call it here
a lean manufacturing.
It led to an effort by
the US to simply copy
what Japan had come up with.
We had to take apart
the Toyota model.
A lot of that work is
being done at MIT, right?
So Dan Rus and
several others at MIT
are writing up the Toyota model.
And explaining it to
the rest of the country
was a really important stage.
Standard industry
approaches like Six Sigma
that came out of
GE have essentially
attempted to incorporate
Japan's quality ideas
and make them pervasive
in US production
for both major
manufacturers, OEM suppliers.
A few other things, there's
something called the product
cycle.
And time is a competitive
factor in this,
so eliminating time
delays and then
something actually the
US really contributed to
was concurrent
engineering design.
So you engineers in
the room I'm sure
know what I'm talking about.
But in other words, if you and
I constituted Chrysler Motors,
the way in which
we would organize
Chrysler Motors in
the old days was
we would have a
bunch of engineers,
and they would do the design.
And then they would
finish the design,
and then they would take it
to the production people.
And the production
people would say, well,
that's all very well and
good, but we can't make that.
So we do it, right?
And then it would be redone.
And then they would take it
to the engineering people
again and then take it
to the marketing people.
And the marketing
people would say, well,
that's all very well and
good, what your engineering
people have done, what your
factory floor people have done,
but we can't sell this thing.
So completely redo it.
In other words, it was a
stage by stage process,
with every stage having a veto.
So the development
process for design
was painful, and lengthy,
and often adversarial.
Concurrent design is to put
all those teams together
at the outset contributing
to the design--
dramatic time savings,
dramatic efficiency savings.
So these are all
kinds of ideas that
came out of this time period.
Another idea that Japan had--
and we weren't
organized this way--
Japan had a whole different
way of approaching what we
could call the labor trade-off.
So Japan had a system of
essentially guaranteed
lifetime employment.
So if you were a
worker in Japan,
you were pretty well
assured in this era.
It's changed a bit now, in
this era of a lifetime job.
And in return for that
assurance of a lifetime job,
management would control the
work rules, or what's actually
happening on the factory floor,
right, now that we processed
where the rule systems is.
That was the trade-off.
The US had a complete
different trade-off.
We treated labor not as a
fixed cost, like Japan did.
We treated it as
a variable cost.
And the trade the unions
insisted on-- this was an era
of pretty heavy unionization
of manufacturing in the US
at the time--
unions weren't
able to affect who
gets hired and fired
in the employment
side of the equation.
But they would control
the workloads, right?
And they designed those to
be as protective as possible
as their workforces, right?
Not necessarily the
most efficient system.
So Japan actually had a
better model here, right?
Now we continue to treat our
workforce as a variable cost,
right?
So whenever there's
an economic downturn,
US companies dump their
workforces as a quick response,
right?
That's fundamental
management theory in the US.
Other countries don't
necessarily do it this way.
Japan has had to get more
flexible in its model
as it's gone to more
global competition.
But it had a completely
different way
of organizing its workforce.
Labor became much more
collaborative, rather than
adversarial, and ready to
leap on new efficiencies
in the production
process, rather than fight
them every inch of the way.
So again, this was a
contributing factor
to the kind of new model
that Japan was creating.
There's another element
here of industrial policy.
So Japan is recovering
from World War II.
It develops an
innovation system that
is very focused on production.
That's what it's got
to stand up against.
And that's where this
quality model comes from,
and these other pieces.
And Japan is very resource poor.
So starting in the
1880s, Japan understood
that it had to have
an export orientation.
It had to export
to live because it
had to get the resources in
order to produce them, right?
And buy those back, so it
needed an export surplus
to be able to do that.
One of its core institutions
was called MITI--
Ministry of International Trade
and Industry-- now called METI.
And the nickname for
this was Japan Inc.
But a very integrated system
of governmental leadership
tied to major industries.
And the major industries
weren't organized
as they were in the US.
We had anti-trust
laws in the US.
We did not really impose
that in the post-war period
and allowed Japan to keep
its, quote, keiretsu system.
So that's a system
of major firms
typically engaged in production
activities, financing,
global trading,
and then networks
of suppliers that
are tied to those.
So these are groups
of related firms
that are all mutually owned and
tied to each other, all right?
They would violate US anti-trust
laws in all likelihood,
but that's the way Japan
organized its core industries.
Now, not all Japanese firms are
part of these keiretsu, right?
So a company like Sony
was actually outside
of this, right?
But most of its
industry was organized
in this very simple kind of way.
And you can see
how their dealings
with a major
governmental entity,
like MITI, could be readily tied
to unify government decision
making and industry
decision making.
So when the US was
competing against Japan
in this quite centralized,
quite efficient model,
US had a lot of trouble coping.
And you've seen them--
when we talked
about Jorgenson, you
saw some of the
productivity and GDP curbs.
So historic US
productivity rate generally
around 2%, and historic US GDP
growth is generally around 3%,
right?
Between '73 and
'91, those plummet,
so we fall to productivity
rates at around 1%
and GDP growth about 2%.
It was a pretty grim time
in the United States.
We were up against a powerful
industrial competitor,
and Japan was able to
take economic sectors
that the US thought
it would always have,
like consumer electronics,
like a large part of the auto
sector.
Because it had a better
innovation model.
So in a very brief
period of time,
that's kind of what
happened in the 70s and 80s.
The US response, as
I suggested earlier,
was that we would attempt
to copy Japan on quality.
And we call it
lean manufacturing,
but we would attempt to
replicate as much as we could
of that Toyota model.
And by and large, our industries
have pretty well done that.
But we also kept a focus on our
very strong innovation system.
So we launched in the 1990s
the IT innovation wave,
which Japan misses, right?
And if you get your economy
to a leadership right
to the edge of the
technological frontier,
and you organize your economy
around leading innovation
ways with Japan and just
organize its economy
around doing, around a
new production system,
and then you miss a wave,
it can be pretty unpleasant,
all right?
So it was unpleasant in the
US when we missed a wave
in the '70s and '80s.
But then things got
tough for Japan.
Now that's not the only
factor that's going on.
There's macroeconomic factors.
There's demographic factors.
There's a series of things that
are occurring simultaneously
in Japan.
But one part of
the story is around
missing this innovation wave.
So that was the kind of response
that the US came up with.
It used its innovation
system to develop effectively
radical innovations
in the IT space
and create whole new industries.
So we pursue radical innovation.
Not consciously--
but in a way, that
was effectively our response.
Why don't we stop there
and go through the sheets
and discussion of Kent Hughes?
RASHEED: Yeah.
So Kent Hughes, I
think he really talks
about sort of this
'80s period in Japan
and then really isolates
the sort of US response.
So how is the US
going to respond
to kind of larger problems
with our manufacturing system
and really competing
on that global scale,
now that Japan has sort of
captured a lot of things going
on with quality manufacturing
and that sort of innovation
wave?
I think one of the
really important things
that he talks about is sort
of this bureaucratic climate.
So there's a lot going
on sort of trading
on the international scale,
but bringing it back home
to the US.
You have to get a lot of
people onboard in order
for you to sort of move
forward in this cohesive way,
unless you're riding
an innovation wave.
And so we're set up in a
radically different way
than Japan.
And we have to kind of
figure out what to do.
And so talking about
Ronald Reagan's response,
I think it was pretty cool and
important that Ronald Reagan
sort of exercises his
discretion with this commission
on industrial competitiveness
with John Young.
So I was just wondering
if any of you guys
had any feelings on sort
of the presidential power
to not only kind of
highlight issues,
but sort of take the
lead and take action,
separate from all the
bureaucratic dealings?
Oh yeah, so Steph, I
saw you raise your hand.
STUDENT 2: Oh, I wanted to
point attention to Matthew.
STUDENT 3: I mean, I thought
when I was reading it,
that he was actually
quite slow to act on it,
and it was really Congress that
kind of pushed the efforts.
And later on, he
decided that this was
something that was important.
Yeah, it seemed more of
like a political at first.
STUDENT 4: Yeah,
or making motions
without actually
making actions, just
to sort of look like Reagan is
taking action on this thing.
And yeah, I agree.
I thought he ended
up dragging his feet,
and other people had to
sort of push for anything
to be enacted with
the Young Commission.
RASHEED: So I think one of
the big pieces in this Young
Commission is how they
decide to choose members.
And they pick kind of large
manufacturers of industry,
and they start with John Young.
But I thought it
was interesting how
he didn't get to sort of hand
pick the members that he'd like
to be on his own commission.
I thought that might be a
little bit short-sighted,
considering he's going to have
to work with all these people.
And it might be a way of
sort of to drag your feet.
But I thought the
sort of what came out
of the commission, which is this
new report, which highlights
a lot of these sort of
transformative things, sort of
would've never happened
if he didn't sort of grab
from all these places in
industry and manufacturers.
But is there any
sort of merit to sort
of bringing these
people in, having
them work on this commission,
and then publish this report?
Even though we don't
sort of act on it,
but you see all of these
things that he highlighted
in sort of New Growth Compact,
maybe 10 years down the line,
might really be important.
And sort of, this
lays the groundwork
for five or 10 years
in the future when
you're ready to sort
of act on these things.
So I guess my goal would
be, is there a merit
to sort of even if it's kind of
haphazard attempt at addressing
the issues, is it a
still important metric,
maybe not now, but five
or 10 years down the line?
STUDENT 4: Yeah, I think so.
And with the Young
Commission, I think
that out of that commission,
Young decided to form--
what's the name?
I'm blanking on it, but
it still exists today.
I looked it up.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: The
Council on Competitiveness.
STUDENT 4: Yes, exactly.
So yes, there are lasting
knowledge and wisdom
from a commission like this.
So yeah, definitely,
it's better than nothing.
It's better than sticking
your head in the ground.
I think some of the
stuff they put forward
is definitely extremely useful.
It's there.
It's published.
It's accessible.
STUDENT 5: I think it's one of
those better late than never
things, right?
Because it only seems
to happen that--
I don't know if this
is a trend with the US
or countries in
general, but it only
seems that they put in all this
effort for one specific issue
when something's
going wrong, right?
Why not prevent things from
going wrong in the first place?
And I don't know.
The government seemed to be very
hesitant to change their ways
surrounding their views
on specific policies
around innovation.
So like I said, better
late than never.
But in my opinion, it'd
be better why didn't they
do this decades before?
STUDENT 2: I think the
question I have with relation
to this reading is
that Hughes largely
characterizes domestic
policy making as reactionary.
And I agree.
What hope exists for utilizing,
A, the courts under the living
constitutionalist framework to
really address these questions
and, or meaningfully
integrating the kinds
of knowledge and
consensus that is
created in these commissions.
And I don't know that
there is yet a model
for effective consensus building
outside of these commissions
and translating that
to policy action
with collaboration in
the legislative branch
and the judicial branch.
And that's, I think, where
your point sort of comes
into action, that
there is an opportunity
for proactive
policymaking, but it
has to be integrated
with discussions
around the branches.
It can't just be
isolated in one branch
because then, as
Hughes pointed out,
there's going to be competition
amongst them on what
the right thing is to do.
RASHEED: Yeah, so that brings
maybe my follow-up question.
You might be able
to help us out here.
So I think the
president, in this way,
really was able to just kind
of use his power to set aside
and kind of call for the
study and commission.
Is there a way for
sort of legislators
to kind of do the same thing?
Let's say I'm a
committee on energy.
Can I call for a study or the
committee section of Congress
that deals with manufacturing?
Can they sort of call for
a study in the same way,
and then maybe work with
the executive branch
to kind of do the same thing?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: I mean, just
a comment from my background
experience having worked in
the Senate for about 15 years--
yes, the committees
of Congress can
function on an ongoing
basis to try and identify,
Kevin, exactly the
problem you were raising,
which is be a
little foresighted.
Some committees are obviously
much better at this than others
historically.
But there's no guarantees.
And frankly, government
tends to respond to crises.
And if there's
not a crisis, it's
hard to get it
mobilized, organizing,
and moving to be foresighted.
That's not necessarily
all bad, right?
There's advantages
of having limits
on governmental
intervention here.
And if the system is
working fairly well,
you probably don't want
government intervention.
It's only when you hit a
crisis moment that you really
want it to fall into place.
I understand,
though, your points
about wouldn't it be
better if we were watching
all this stuff all the time.
So there is that reality.
You've got to hope that somebody
somewhere in the society
is undertaking that review.
But it's not something
government is terribly good at.
And a typical response to a
crisis in a short term kind
of way.
So we came up with these
various mechanisms,
none could really be called
a competitiveness strategy.
We came up with a
bunch of pieces, right?
One piece that's not
on here was Symantec,
which is an attempt to
deal with Japan's effort
to really capture the
semiconductor sector, which,
again, produced very
high quality production
capabilities and in
semiconductor chips,
particularly DRAMs.
And the US was producing
a lot of chips,
but they were not
as high quality.
And the manufacturing
process was not as efficient
as Japan was.
So Canon and Nikon
were opposed to be
able to capture a very
large part of that sector.
The solution the
US came up with--
and again, this is DoD--
the Department of Defense--
which viewed semiconductors
as a pretty critical
national security technology.
Because it was embedded in
all kinds of critical defense
technologies.
DoD agreed to cost share
with the big industry
organization consisting of both
the semiconductor fabricators,
but also the supplier system,
the equipment and parts
suppliers system for
the semiconductor
in this community.
That community came
together, eventually settled
on a series of steps
to build quality
into the US semiconductor
manufacturing process.
Cost shared with DARPA, and it
really turned around a sector.
Now there are other
developments going on here, too.
The US taking leadership
of integrated circuits
and microprocessors, kind of
the next stage of technology,
so that certainly helped.
But nonetheless, the
effort to drive quality
into semiconductor production
was a very concrete example
of an industry and
governmental collaboration
that actually worked.
So these other pieces here
are a little more hands-off--
CRETA, Bayh-Dole Act, the
Advanced Technology Program,
but not as direct.
Symantec was a
fairly direct effort
in the particular
economic sector
with national security
ramifications to intervene.
So in some ways, that's
the most seminal model that
came out of this time period.
But again, the minute
that the IT revolution
starts to take off at the
beginning of the '90s, then
the US drops its concern
with manufacturing, right?
And we go on to having a great
time for a decade with the IT
revolution, which,
as we discussed,
is a remarkable period of growth
and of economic well-being
in the US.
How about another one, RASHEED?
RASHEED: For Hughes?
Yeah, I think we kind
of center our discussion
a little bit on the US response
to what's going on in Japan.
But I thought it might be
interesting to at least touch
on how the different
paradigms-- and so
the US and Japanese culture.
So in Japan, we've talked about
kind of like these workers
treating labor as a big source.
And so you're sort
of employed for life.
These paradigms
play out in Japan,
and they're just kind of
characteristics of the culture.
But I think looking at
international trade,
is this sort of the
first time that we
had to deal with a
difference in paradigm
affecting international
trade, and basically just
the fundamentals
of the US economy
in a pretty large
and widespread way?
Because I guess,
globalization will
bring new countries
and new actors
acting in different ways.
But there's sort
of no competition
until Japan sort of poses
this entirely different model
for how to do things.
But I'd like to at least touch
on how does kind of setting up
your problem and your
paradigms in this way,
does that provide opportunity
for sort of new innovation
ways, in that if I set up
postwar Japan in a slightly
different way, do I get a
slightly different outcome?
STUDENT 4: I was wondering--
this might help answer that--
does Japan have the equivalent
of the US labor union?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Yeah, the labor unions
are organized very
differently however--
far less adversarial.
Again, if you have a lifetime
guarantee of work what's
there to fight about, right?
Why do you want to
have fights, right?
Instead, they're much more
collaborative institutions
that tend towards moving
towards great efficiency
to promote their
company's performance.
There's much greater incentive
for collaboration in the system
that they set up.
Now again, some of
that is faded as Japan
has entered a much more
globalized competitive world
of competition than it faced
as its system was emerging.
But the trade-off of getting
cooperation from labor
around work rules in return
for a lifetime employment
has tended to work
well for Japan.
In fact, the US auto
industry was actually
moving in that direction for
a time period before, again,
high competition kind
of caught up with it.
But it's just that labor
trade-off is just a completely
different arrangement.
Look, I don't want to
underestimate these big macro
factors that are
playing here, right?
So at the end of the
World War II era, the US
and the developed world--
non-Communist
world-- essentially
came to a set of arrangements
around free trade concepts,
and open economies, and lowering
tariff and trade barriers
and so forth.
And that was the consensus
system of the time.
When Japan organized its
economy and really began
to move on entry as a
global economic power,
it organized around a
different set of concepts.
It was not organized around
a free trading system.
It was organized around a
pretty mercantilist approach.
Again, as part of
Japan's history,
it has to trade to survive.
It has to export
to survive, right?
So they developed a very
focused export system.
They undervalue their currency
so that their manufacturers
would always have a
price advantage over US
manufacturers, right?
US put up with that
for essentially world
national security kind
of reasons with an ally.
And we assumed we were
kings of manufacturing.
Who could interfere with us?
Japan had a much more
interventionist attitude
by its government into
supporting particular
and assisting particular firms.
That was not like the US system.
It made it very
hard for imports,
particularly of
complex technologies,
to enter the Japanese markets.
So it was playing by a different
set of more mercantilist
kinds of rules.
And frankly, that
model became a model
for other Asian economies.
So that was a model that worked
for Taiwan, and for Korea,
and now China.
And it's not based on that open
trading regime consensus policy
that the US tried to build
at the end of World War II.
So we're up against different
economic models here.
Part of the story is that
the US hasn't really figured
out what the right strategy is.
But RASHEED, I think I
interrupted your ability
to get answers to your
question from the table.
RASHEED: A little bit.
Yeah, so definitely
wanted to talk
about some of these
Japanese paradigms
kind of being a little bit
more pervasive in the way
that they set up,
just like in the way
they set up their whole
economic structure.
And is there an opportunity
for different countries
to sort of adopt different
paradigms in this way?
STUDENT 3: To an extent.
I think it almost goes
back to that discussion
we had about our innovation
systems that makes them
[INAUDIBLE].
And I think while that
paradigm worked well
for Asian countries, I think
there would definitely be still
a lot of resistance in the
US if we tried to set up
an identical paradigm here.
People have these strong
beliefs about free trade
and laissez-faire government.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Right, although those
are now right at the center of
a major political debate, really
for the first time since--
well, there was a debate over
these issues in the 1970s
and '80s, a big
debate as Japan came
to the forefront in two major
economic sectors in particular.
And we're back to
that debate now.
We're having it right now.
And so all of this is actually
pretty interesting context
to be watching, I think.
We'll have to see what the
new administration proposes,
but they appear to be moving in
much more of a neo mercantilist
kind of direction
than prior regimes.
STUDENT 6: So in order to
figure out whether or not,
not only if other
countries can try
to convert their
economies to this,
but rather, whether they
should, we have to figure out
what was the--
so one of the main blocks
between any economy and Japan's
economy is these kinds of--
what was the term you had for
those things like railroad
monopolies and oil monopolies?
Oh yeah--
STUDENT 3: Business sectors?
STUDENT 6: What?
STUDENT 4: Business sectors?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Industrial policy.
STUDENT 6: It's the
regulations that keep it from--
STUDENT 5: Antitrust.
STUDENT 6: Thank you.
Sorry.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: All right.
STUDENT 6: Yeah, we're
on the same wavelength.
OK, so those antitrust
laws, we have
to figure out what is it
specifically within Japan that
would conflict with those laws.
And well, is it
really the best system
for the individual worker?
So from the impression
that I've gotten,
the government is
so closely linked
with the industrial sector.
I feel like it would be an--
I'm not sure how that
transition could occur.
It's kind of like because they
had come out from World War II,
they had the opportunity to
restructure from the ground up.
So I'm not sure
if you could take
an economy that's already based,
even if it's a better system.
And I'm not sure you
could just revamp it,
at least in any
reasonable amount of time.
STUDENT 7: I do agree with
that in that there's also
historical and cultural
factors to consider, like a lot
about how America views itself
as you're pulling yourself
up by your bootstraps and
competitively getting ahead,
less so than this kind
of more collaborative,
industrial conglomerate that
is making sure everyone's OK.
So I think it could
encounter resistance
in cultures like ours, where
that's not as respected.
STUDENT 8: Yeah, I
think also there's
the issue of scalability.
Because Japan is so much of a
smaller country than the US,
their structure
might not translate
well on a broader scale
to ours, especially
with the cultural difference.
Because I know
educationally, it's
very much pretty structured.
If you do these things and
you go to these schools,
you tend to go
get slotted in, so
to speak, into certain
industries and certain roles.
And that's kind of an
approach that we've
tried to avoid going
towards here in the US.
We kind of promote, oh, you
can go into whatever field
you want.
You don't necessarily have
to go on a certain path.
So I think there's
definitely differences
fundamentally in
ideology that prevents
kind of the same model being
imposed upon both countries.
STUDENT 6: Regarding at
least the scalability thing,
you could possibly counter
that by saying, well,
we have a lot of states.
So you theoretically could
just have a couple of states
just try a similar system.
It'd be easier to
revamp them because it's
a much smaller area.
It's fewer people.
So I mean, of course, there's
still plenty of reasons why you
can't or why you shouldn't.
But it definitely would
make it a lot easier
to do, or at least look at.
STUDENT 5: Yeah, I think
just to add on to that,
I think one of the writers
from the first class
actually has a whole--
he's written a lot about
these sanctuary cities.
I think that's the
wrong term, but he
talks about cities where
they have special rules
for certain industries.
And that's also
especially important
because especially
in the last election,
there's only certain
cities that are really
doing well because of technology
since San Francisco, New York.
I'm probably
forgetting a couple--
a lot.
But what he is really
pushing is like, OK, well,
we're going to get jobs
in this sector in Detroit,
and we're going to get jobs
in this sector in Houston
and bring them back.
And that was kind of
what he was arguing.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So
I'm going to cut this off,
so we can make progress
with some of the readings.
But I think this is a
good background for us
to lead into--
I mean, you all raising these
cultural historical things
would be great background when
we hit our discussion of Korea
and also how Japan had to try
and reorganize its innovation
system as it got to the
frontier in Glen Fong's piece.
So hang on to a
lot of these ideas.
Let me jump to the
next reading here,
which I'm going to go
through just very briefly.
We're now back.
It's post 1990s, right?
We're now back in our time
with that as a backdrop.
I put this reading in here
by Barry Lynn and a book
that he wrote called
End of the Line.
It's not a book that I have
a lot of agreement with,
but there's an interesting
historical perspective here
that I especially want
you to get a handle on,
particularly given
the conversation we've
had about industry and culture.
So Barry Lynn argues
that there's essentially
three periods of
US manufacturing
industrial history.
There is a period between
Alexander Hamilton.
And we call it 1945, the
end of World War II, right?
And I mean, Hamilton is a
absolutely critical figure
in US economic history because
he had a remarkably big picture
of what the US
economy could become,
a bigger picture than
anybody of this time
in the political system.
So and his fundamental
understanding
was that in this era of
a small new power faced
with much larger contending
European nations,
that the only way that the
US keeps its independence
is by building a strong
independent commercial economy,
right?
So Thomas Jefferson
at the same time
is devoted to an
agricultural economy
and a concept of young farmer.
And that's how democracy
is going to take place.
Hamilton is working in a
completely different direction.
Let's stand up a major
national banking system.
commercial economy.
And he himself is strongly
dedicated to early US
manufacturing industry.
So he's investing in an early
manufacturing plant across New
York City and in New Jersey.
So Hamilton's
concept was that we
need to pursue
rational national self
dependence in manufacturing.
And tariffs are
fine because that
will ensure the growth of US
manufacturing and production
capability in the US economy.
And he creates a lot of the
fundamental institutions
that frankly, we still rely
on in maintaining that very
small commercial economy.
Then there is the post-World War
II emergence of the Cold War.
And Lynn argues that
the US government
leaves its Hamiltonian
notions of national self
dependence in manufacturing to
build a larger concept, right?
Confronted with an
international confrontation
with a different
economic system,
the US works towards building
a world economy that integrates
the US, Europe, and
Japan in particular,
and other nations, too.
But those are the
principal ones--
in a system of mutual
dependence, right?
So this is not a self
dependent manufacturing system.
This starts to move
us in the direction
of a multi-continent
production system that's
going to be shared
by the participants.
And then Lynn argues that
the third stage really
occurs in the 1990s as President
Clinton moves to move China
into the world economic system.
And that notion there is a--
it's a similar notion
to what occurs in Europe
in the post-war period.
That if they integrate
their economies
and they all own
each other, they're
never going to fight
World War II again.
All right?
There's a lot to be said
for that concept, frankly.
That an economically
interdependent integrated world
is going to significantly
reduce national security threats
over time.
That's essentially,
Barry Lynn argues,
Clinton's driving
conceptual framework
that this interdependent
economic system, tied
by joint manufacturing
and a common set
of economic organizations,
will enable world peace, right?
That's the notion.
So the WTO agreement and
China's entry into the WTO
is the critical
enabling step here.
And the west production
system is indeed,
to a significant extent,
merged into China
with China's production
output going worldwide.
Now there's a whole defense set
of perspectives here, right?
There are integrationists,
which Clinton would be one,
according to Lynn,
essentially extending
a Western manufacturing
production system into China,
will bind China to a
global economic system,
substantially reducing
national security problems
in the long term.
And then there's a
whole different school
of the list of his profound
differences in these nations
and their geopolitical
systems, geopolitical goals
and their political systems
that are going to endure,
and the only question
is which nation
gains the advantage from the
economic interdependence.
But the next thing
that Lynn argues
is that this
globalism has created
its own economic
determinism, right?
That a new global
economic system
has in fact emerged here that
nobody's really in charge of,
right?
That nobody-- no
separate country,
or even groups of
countries, can manage--
that it's larger than the
ability of these countries
to manage.
So Lynn writes this before
the 2008 financial meltdown,
which is truly a
world phenomenon,
driven by failures
in this country,
but pervasive worldwide.
And then there is
these frantic moments
as countries try
to figure out how
to manage this global
financial crisis
and realize how lacking in
tools they are to cope with it.
So kind of a final
point that Lynn makes
is that we've now
created a system that's
larger than the countries
themselves, right?
It's largely, frankly,
deterministic and somewhat
independent of them.
And the ability to intervene
becomes much more problematic.
All right, so I thought it was
just an interesting perspective
to kind of throw
into the mix here,
as we begin to think about some
of these historical questions
and try to think about
the kind of global economy
that we've made.
So who's got that one?
RASHEED: I think it's still me.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Really?
RASHEED: Yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Thanks, RASHEED.
RASHEED: Yeah, we can
take it from there.
So I thought we'd comment on
kind of the interconnectedness
and globalism might be
very specific to this time.
I think he wrote about 2000.
And so he's like probably just
come from the '90s and seeing
Clinton sort of definitely push
towards laissez-faire business
practices on the international
scale, which is something
that, yeah, as Americans
we're pretty used
to this whole idea
of the government
is very separate from
business ideals and business
practices, but
also the promotion
that now it's not
just the US that
has to operate in the system.
But now we have to deal
with other countries that
promote this.
And so I thought it was pretty
important that we kind of date
him in 2000, where
we're kind of riding
the high of a lot
of these promotion
of international
interdependence.
But we do see the trouble,
I guess, definitely in 2008.
So is there sort of
room for us not only
as we develop in sort of this
interconnected globalized
world?
Is there room for
regulation and sort
of do intergovernmental
business practices that
have to be put in place to
sort of keep us in check?
STUDENT 5: OK, to add
on to that and also add
a fourth perspective,
so Andy Grove
was one of the three
founders of Intel.
And their big focus and
their main working ability
as a company was manufacturing,
especially very detailed
complex manufacturing.
And so he actually
wrote a letter in 2010,
and then he passed away in 2016.
But he wrote one about why
we need more manufacturing
in the US and why it's
dangerous when we don't have it.
And he goes on to say, Mr.
Grove contrasted the startup
phase of a business.
What uses for new
technologies are identified
with the scale-up phase?
When technology goes from
prototype to mass production,
both are important.
But only scale-up is an
engine for job growth.
And scale-up in
general no longer
occurs in the United States.
Without scaling, he wrote,
we don't just lose jobs.
We lose our hold
on new technologies
and ultimately damage
our capacity to innovate.
He then goes on to
talk a little bit
about laissez-faire
and open markets.
But then he argues that
even though laissez-faire
and those principles are good,
there is room for improvement.
He talks about job centric
economies and politics,
where in a job centric
system, job creation would
be the nation's
number one objective,
while the government's setting
priorities and arraigning
the forces necessary
to achieve the goal.
And within this operating, not
only in their immediate profit
interest, but also in
the interest of employees
and employees yet
to be hired, which
is beneficial to the country.
He ends with saying
something that we're
seeing right now, which is
wealth inequality, that if we
do have a place where we
just pretty much outsource
everything, we're going
to have a country that
has very high profitability,
but low prosperity, which
is what we're seeing right now,
and especially very impactful
in the last three years.
Especially since after
2000-- well, in the 2000s,
everyone started to outsource
all their manufacturing
because it's cheaper
in China, Asia.
But that's really hurt jobs
in the US in a statement.
STUDENT 4: Sorry--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Thanks, Martin.
STUDENT 4: Who wrote that?
STUDENT 5: Andy Grove.
So--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: One of
the three founders of Intel.
STUDENT 5: And he was also
very important because he--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Andy Grove also
has one of my favorite
remarks, which is
that only the paranoid survive.
STUDENT 5: Yeah.
He's written a lot
of great books,
but the differences
and the reason
I added him is because
his perspective is more
of the business
person who's seen kind
of the impact versus
the three sources
added were mostly politicians.
And so I thought that would
be interesting to add.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Thanks, Martin.
And look, a lot of the
issues you just raised
are going to be prime topics
in next week's class, too.
So just hang on
to a lot of that.
We can discuss it here,
too, of course, but--
STUDENT 2: Would it be
acceptable and, or appropriate
to do a straw poll of who agreed
overall with Lynn's argument
versus who didn't?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
With Barry Lynn?
STUDENT 2: Yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Sure.
STUDENT 2: Can we straw poll?
Who generally thought
that [INAUDIBLE]??
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Now
which part of his argument?
STUDENT 2: I mean--
oh, so I think the
piece I was missing
in your analysis about
his argument on Clinton
is that he didn't think
that was a good idea.
He didn't appreciate
the integrative approach
because he felt that the
invisible hand that we had all
presumed to exist that would
effectively regulate the market
and ensure that everyone
was acting in not only
their own
self-interest, but also
in the self-interest of the
system being sustainable
was dangerous.
Because it could
collapse, and then it did.
So overall, I agree
with that component.
And I guess, that's what I'm
curious about other people's
perspectives on.
Do we think that his
conception of how
laissez-faire is implemented
is generally applicable or not?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
I mean, look,
that's a good summary of the
point that Lynn brings us to.
So thank you for
pushing on that.
RASHEED: Agree
with some caveats.
STUDENT 7: Oh, we're voting?
STUDENT 6: Yeah.
STUDENT 2: OK,
yeah, let's start.
STUDENT 5: Let's simplify
the statement, though.
STUDENT 6: Yeah.
STUDENT 5: Just keep
it as a true-false.
STUDENT 6: Yeah.
Yeah.
STUDENT 2: Do we think
laissez-faire economies
are dangerous in the way that
Lynn has articulated them?
Yes, do we?
STUDENT 6: Yeah, pretty much.
STUDENT 2: OK, who does not?
Who does not?
Who thinks laissez-faire
is good with caveats?
OK.
STUDENT 6: Have you heard
of the Great Depression?
RASHEED: So I think my
caveats were definitely
you had this opportunity in
laissez-faire to sort of spread
this idea of not only
comparative advantage,
but you also spread, hopefully,
if this works, positively
sort of like the good things.
And if you hit maybe
Martin's point on bring in--
job creation is kind of
one of the central pieces,
just sort of keeping
the social tide of sort
of everybody rising.
I think you get an opportunity
to sort of like spread the job
creation, sort of spread all
these things with laissez-faire
and looking, like
Clinton did, towards sort
of not so much outsourcing,
but sort of like looking bigger
than just kind of creating
jobs in the United States
to sort of rise our wealth.
But if you look at if
you can create jobs now
all over the globe and integrate
them into this interconnected
system, you have the opportunity
to sort of rise the tide
globally in laissez-faire.
STUDENT 7: I just think the main
point I got from Lynn's reading
is that systems with single
point failures are dangerous.
And I feel like that would
be true on any scale.
He's just talking about
now we're on such a
bigger scale that it's
going to affect everyone.
But I think that at
the national scale,
that would still be dangerous.
Any system that has single
point failures is a concern.
But I don't necessarily
agree with the fact
that he thinks that
can't be corrected,
while still having a somewhat
laissez-faire system.
I mean, I do think it would
require some regulations,
but even if it was just
having a few plants that
makes semiconductors
outside of Taiwan,
I feel like that could
be not a huge imposition
on laissez-faire and reduce this
single point failure problem.
STUDENT 3: Actually, when I was
reading that, I was thinking,
would it really be safer then
to have every factory making
every component of the phone
all in the United States?
Wouldn't that just
geographically cause
you to be less diverse?
STUDENT 9: Yeah, I
think that's interesting
because he uses
language to make it seem
like this is what a globally
distributed architecture looks
like.
But I agree.
I think if you have all of
your manufacturing or something
concentrated in one geographical
area, it's not globalization.
It's not really a very
complex integrated system.
It just happens to be far
away from your country.
That doesn't make it local.
STUDENT 2: Would we
conceive of Lynn's argument
as America first then?
STUDENT 8: Yeah, I've
been thinking about that.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Yeah, I mean, Lynn
is painting a dark side here.
And he's painting a portrayal
of opening up the system.
And then the system itself
begins to take control, right?
This globalized
financial system itself
begins to take
control and minimize
the ability of
any of the players
to impact or affect that.
So it's a fundamental statement
about the fragility and lack
of resilience.
And your single point of failure
point is well taken, Chloe.
It's a dark picture here,
and what makes it intriguing
and the only reason why
I still keep it in here
is that sure enough, that's
exactly what we ended up
with in 2008.
And boy, that was
so close to a really
massive worldwide depression
that it's painful in economy.
So I put it in as kind of
a useful warning lesson,
but also a lesson
about how we've
moved in the international
organization of our economy
from a nation-centered
to an ally-centered
to a truly globalized
kind of orientation here.
And what are the
implications of that?
We need to keep
thinking about this.
STUDENT 8: Going
back to that whole--
the 2008 collapse,
you were saying
that it's very
difficult to regulate
some sort of financial system
that reaches across borders.
But at least with the 2008
crisis, a lot of the collapse
stemmed directly
from the US, which
means that at least with
the collapse of that form,
US regulations clearly would
have helped significantly
and would have prevented
the crisis altogether.
So my feeling is at least
if we're going to use that
as the example,
then it just isn't--
I don't know.
I don't know how true it is
then that we can't actually
regulate this system.
Because if you have all these
countries that are all--
ignoring natural disasters,
like what happened in Taiwan,
if all these separate countries
are regulating their industries
properly in order to make
sure that no bank is,
quote unquote, too
big to fail, then
I don't see how the
system could collapse
if all the individual components
are doing what they should be.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So let me
put this in a different way
here.
We've been targeting
an innovation wave.
I think this
significant argument
that the explosion of
the financial services
sector, incredibly rapid growth
in financial services sector,
in the 1990s, in the 2000s,
that's an innovation wave.
There certainly were
technological innovations
that were at the heart of this.
The IT revolution was clearly
a great organizing factor.
The ability to bring
mathematics to bear,
to work on a problem of big data
and initial kinds of analytics
to bring algorithms to
bear on market trading--
these were all significant
technology advances
that were enablers of creating
a truly globalized system.
And we moved at a
relatively short period
from national systems, financial
services and financial service
organizations to much
larger global systems.
So when the US
economy went down,
it hit the rest of
the world economy.
US financial system went down.
It hit the rest of the
world economy in wave
after wave after wave
and began to jeopardize
a whole nest of other
financial institutions
that were caught up in this
very integrated kind of system.
So that's more of what
I'm driving at, Max.
And look, as we've discussed
in innovation waves,
there's always a bubble, right?
And the problem
with having a bubble
in your financial
services sector
is that it brings
down everything.
It's one thing to have
a bubble with dot coms.
Yeah, lose the dot
coms, but if you
lose the world
financial system because
of the technological bubble,
it's pretty powerful.
Andrew Lowe is a wonderful
professor of finance
here at MIT.
Has a remarkable chart, right?
The chart is-- it's the
history of the value
of home prices adjusted for
inflation in the United States.
And it's a hockey stick.
OK, so it's inflation adjusted.
It's flat, and the
numbers start getting put
together in about the 1880s.
And should you go on the 1880s,
there's the Great Depression,
right?
A couple of recessions,
but it's pretty stable.
Then about 1990, it
just skyrockets, right?
It just skyrockets, and you
wonder what were we thinking?
I mean, this is clearly
going to be a bubble.
Why was it that the financial
services sector decided
that the ultimate fundamental
unit of value in the world
financial order is going to
be the American home mortgage?
Why did we do this, right?
What were we thinking?
But in a way, that's
exactly what we do.
Now, Andrew goes on
to make an argument.
We developed all these very
interesting new financial tools
in the course of
that innovation wave.
He wouldn't necessarily
call it an innovation wave,
but I would.
Let's figure out
if we can settle
on some better units of
value than the American home
mortgage, right?
Is there a way to drive
investment, which we can now
mobilize on a global scale on
to much better units of value?
So the project he's been
involved in has been,
can we drive it on
innovation based research?
Can we create agglomerations
of, really, major capital?
Not just $60 billion a
year in a $19 trillion
economy of venture capital,
but real numbers, right?
And move those larger numbers
on in the innovation system.
So he's working on health
research in particular.
But it's an interesting concept.
And in a way, it
comes out of trying
to wrestle with
some of the points
that Barry Lynn kind of
put on the table here.
RASHEED, a closing thought?
RASHEED: Yeah.
So I think Barry
Lynn probably takes
maybe a different
position than in the time
that he was talking
about her, too.
I think if he had said this
in the room with Bill Clinton,
he would have had an
interesting discussion.
But I was actually
just wondering
if we could talk about
this, like a little bit more
of the critical reception.
And [INAUDIBLE] is he the first
guy to say maybe laissez-faire
wasn't a good idea, guys?
And then we see the
after effects afterwards.
But critically, I think reading
this, I was pretty kind of
taken aback by a lot of
the things he was saying.
Is this sort of maybe not
politically, but socially
acceptable thought in
the US in maybe 2005?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah,
it's a moment of dissidence
in our reading list, right?
It's a little contrarian.
So just like Charles Schulz
was contrary in last week,
Barry Lynn is
contrary in this week.
So, good summary.
Thank you, RASHEED.